settle in for another great sleeve neon
moment ho so Gayle King on CBS this
morning put her through a lightning
round of questions and these are the
answers that she gave different song on
your playlist it's not yours too many
but healthy songs and CI and I love SIA
I love her a movie you can watch over
and over all of them whatever my kids
once because I love them so much they
pick the movie
even if I've watched them you're
watching 65 times bigger but for example
my Monsters Inc is yeah is so great and
then she needs you to bang bang and
Nanny McPhee oh I can't I can't you pick
one a show you recently been what is
binge that you just watched first
episode second episode third episode
port you just watched it all in one
setting I really watch TV TV but Sheldon
I love that show I love that show I bet
your kids liked that show I love that
show young Sheldon I love that you young
son favorite meal it's not really a meal
it's different things I love peanut
butter so bad peanut butter oh that's
good jelly peanut butter jelly peanut
butters you beat a bit of Judah would a
baseball be putted on is the best the
best and you know that they did this
sort of rapid thing because Celine's a
long answer right so they're like why
don't we just do like a rapid thing
right so just get her to do one-word
answers like this like sort of fast off
the cuff bang she seems very unsure of
Oliver and what's your favorite meal
it's not really a meal lunch over and
over again but no and I'll tell you one
of the things I mean there's so many
things that's charming about Celine Dion
but one of the things that she's always
had is this she she's fine with what she
doesn't know you watch all these
interviews of Celine Dion if somebody
asked her something where she
legitimately doesn't know the answer she
will always just say I don't
know what that is I don't know didn't
you what bingeing that she's so she's
always been that way and it's awesome
chemist asleep is wonderful such an icon
she's just like God she's just no it's
not really a meal just peanut Sheldon Oh